The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
TOMER ULLMAN: What we're
going to do in the last
section is not so much
have a lecture as a debate.
And it's going to be a
debate between myself
and Laura Schultz.
And hopefully at
the end, all of you
can join in for some
sort of free for all.
Although, of course,
you're welcome to ask
questions at any moment.
Now, Laura and I have had
this debate a few times now.
It's a debate about where
do new ideas come from.
It's about theories.
It's about imagination.
The last time that we were
supposed to have the debate
was in SRCD, which is a
child development conference.
But Laura couldn't make it.
So I ended up pulling
a Monty Python man
wrestles with
himself routine where
I was arguing both my
point and Laura's point.
So it's nice to have a
sparring partner again
after that experience.
I am still a little intimidated.
Just to give you a sense of
the caliber of my opponent--
the reason Laura didn't
show up to our SRCD debate
was that she was giving
a talk of her own
in something called TED.
I don't know if
you've heard of SRCD,
but presumably
you've heard of TED.
OK.
So what's this debate about?
What am I talking about?
Here's a 65 second prologue
sort of setting it up.
And then we'll get into it.
The background to this
debate is that, you know,
we have this sort of really
nice picture coming out
of development and models.
And sort of Laura and Josh
have set up the perfect intro
to that, which is
from development
we have this idea of children
are sort of like scientists
or hackers or what have you.
They come up with these
theories to explain the world.
And they do it beautifully.
And that's what they
do in development.
And then we have
this idea coming out
of computational
land which is, well,
what we mean by theories--
how do we actually
capture that computationally?
How do we formalize that?
Well, maybe it's something
like hierarchical learning
over space of programs, right?
Because programs
are this the thing
that's kind of like theories.
And they kind of
explain the world.
And you can learn them via
Bayesian inference and programs
over programs and
learning over learning.
And that's sort of a
really nice picture.
But a lot of people--
Josh I think was
using the phrase--
or Nour was using the
phrase-- "give us grief."
A lot of people give grief
to these computation models
correctly.
They say something
like, wait a minute.
These computational models
that you've described,
like Josh was
describing earlier,
these hierarchical
programs over programs,
what's the theory
space on that, right?
Like, what's the space
of all possible programs?
Remind me.
Isn't that infinite?
And isn't infinite
really, really big?
What are you trying to
suggest, that children are just
searching through this
giant space of programs?
How could they
possibly be doing that?
And what we'd like to
argue and I'll spell out
is that while we don't
search through the space
of all programs, we don't
do that when we write out
our programs, right?
We somehow figure it out.
We're writing out
these infinite spaces.
And yet we search
them in our computers.
That's what we're
try to suggest.
The same way that we search
them in our computers
might be something like the
way the children actually have
to search for their theories.
And it's hard, grueling work
for computers and children.
And the algorithms that we're,
in particular, interested
in-- there's all sorts of
learning algorithms, of course.
But one of the most
influential learning
algorithms that people have
used for learning these programs
and hierarchical programs
over programs and things
like that is just sort of this
version of stochastic search.
And I've told you a little bit
about that-- those of you who
went to the church tutorial--
about Markov Chain Monte
Carlo, and all that stuff.
But the point is
something-- well,
the way to search large,
complicated theory spaces
is through something
like stochastic search.
And, well, if it's something
like stochastic search
algorithms for our
theories, maybe children
are doing something like
stochastic search, right?
No is what Laura's going to say.
Or she is going to say
that can't possibly
be the whole story, and
here's what's missing.
So does everyone
sort of understand
what the debate is going
to be about more or less?
I'm going to spell out,
of course, all of this
in the next few minutes.
OK.
So as I said, we're going
to switch back and forth,
Laura and I.
The outline of the
debate is that I'm
going to give some
background for like what
good our theory is or
presenting a good theory--
just really sort
of covered that.
So I'll be zooming
through it just
to give you an example of
what I'm talking about.
Because I want to tell you what
stochastic search in theory
space looks like.
After I do that, Laura
is going to step in.
And she's going to
rudely interrupt
me and say, no, no, no.
That can't possibly be true.
Here's all the things
that are wrong with that.
I will then give a rebuttal.
And then Laura will
end and summarize.
Beyond all these things,
something I didn't write
was all of you.
Jump in and say what you think.
OK.
So what good is a theory?
Like I said, Josh sort
of went through this.
I don't think you guys need that
much convincing at this point.
But by theory, I mean some
sort of structured knowledge
that goes beyond
the data, compresses
the data in some way, and is
able to predict new things.
My running example
is going to be
much simpler than character
recognition or anything
like that.
It's going to be about
magnets and, in particular,
very simplified
theory of magnetism.
So suppose we bring
a child into the lab.
And we tell her,
look at these blocks.
They all look the same.
Play with them.
See if you can figure
out what's going on here.
OK?
And unbeknownst to the
child, but beknownst to you,
is that these
things are magnets.
They're not just blocks.
Some of them are metal.
Some of them are magnets.
Some of them are plastic.
OK?
So she's going to start
playing with them.
And she's going to start
noticing something.
Like, sometimes none of these
things do anything, right?
They don't stick.
But sometimes,
huh, they do stick.
And she starts
collecting observations
in something like this.
Like, how could she
explain the data?
Well, she could explain
the data in this.
You can just write it down.
She could like
label these somehow.
She could have
all these, A to I.
And she could say, well, A
and B attract one another,
B and A attract one another,
B and C attract one another,
and so on.
OK?
That's her theory.
That's her explanation
of the data.
This is horrible,
of course, right?
Like, this is not an explanation
in any sense of the word.
It's just a table of data.
But in one sense, why
is it not a theory?
It's because it's just writing
down what you've already seen.
It doesn't compress
it in any way.
And it can't predict
anything new.
If I now give you a new block
X and I tell you, listen,
X attracts B, what else
can you tell me about it?
And she'll say, well,
X attracts B. Yeah.
OK.
That's what my table tells me.
You can't really
predict anything new
from a giant table like that.
You want some sort
of compression.
You want some sort of theory.
But what else could she
come up with, right?
There's all sorts of things
you could come up with.
But she could have come
up with a very simplified
theory that goes like this.
Suppose that we
imagine that there are
certain things in the world.
We're just going to call them,
like, shmagnet and shmetal.
Because I don't
want to confuse it
with actual magnets
and actual metals.
But she comes up with a name.
She says there are several
things in the world.
And how do these things
interact with one another?
Well, let's just
hypothesize some rules.
And we can talk about how does
she come up with these rules.
How does she know that there's
two things in the world?
Let's say for some
reason by dumb luck
she hits upon this,
which is actually
a really good theory
for explaining
that, which is to say there
are two things in the world.
And the way they interact
is through these rules.
If something is a magnet and
another thing is a magnet,
if X is a magnet
and Y is the magnet,
they're going to interact.
They're going to stick.
If X is a magnet and Y in the
metal they're going to stick.
And interactions are symmetric.
OK.
So metals don't stick to metals,
but metals stick to magnets.
Magnets sticks to metals.
And the interactions
are symmetric.
And if you have
these rules, you need
to pay some overhead, obviously,
for remembering the rules.
But you can compress this,
you know, n by n thing
into just the vectors
of remembering
what are the magnets,
what are the magnets.
So you've achieved
some compression.
And if I give you something
new and I tell you, look,
this is X, X attracts A, and
you're like, wait a minute.
A is a magnet.
So this is either a
magnet or a metal.
You can probably predict
a lot of different things
about this thing.
You can go and design
your little experiment
to figure out if this new thing
is itself a magnet or a metal.
Great.
So this is wonderful.
I won't go through something.
Like, there's this added
thing of finding out
which one are the actual
shmagnets and shmetals.
And then you can predict
the observed data.
OK.
So now, what we've done is
we've set up this sort of space
of possible theories, right?
Imagine like all the
possible logical theories
that you could have
written out, of all
the possible logical
predicates, there's
an infinite amount of them.
But now we've turned this into
a rational inference problem,
right?
The problem for
you as the learner
is out of the space of all
possible theories, just
find the one that best explains
the observed data, right?
Where, by best we mean something
like Bayes' law, right?
Try to find the best
theory to predict the data,
whereby we mean
the theory that's
sort of the shortest and most
compressed in itself a priori.
You've all seen Bayes' rule.
You've all heard Josh talk
about this and other people.
But it also explains the
data itself the best.
That's the problem.
Go figure it out.
We formalize it for you.
We've solved it.
And, of course, you know,
this elides a lot of things.
It doesn't really
solve anything.
But we'll get to
that in a second.
So you might wonder
like how do we
build a good space
for possible theories.
And one way to do
then is to say, well,
how do you generate
all possible theories?
How do you define a space
of all possible theories?
In this case, we're just
going to go with grammar.
But you could imagine
something like a generator
for all possible
programs, right?
So a grammar, to put it
very, very, very shortly,
is something that
you can run forward
and will generate a sentence.
Or it's a way of sort of
looking at the sentence
and figuring out what
its underlying rules are.
Let's put it this way, OK?
So in a grammar, you would start
with a sort of a sentence node.
And then you know
that a sentence
can go into several other
nodes in some probability.
For example, a sentence
node can go into something
like a verb phrase
and a noun phrase.
The noun phrase goes into
a noun and another thing.
And you sort generate
through this grammar
until you end up
with a sentence.
And it can be any
sort of sentence.
It can be the clownfish ascended
the stairs darkly, right?
And you can run
this grammar forward
and generate whole new
sentences that you've never
thought of it before.
And you could then
also use that grammar
to figure out sentences.
So if you see the sentence, the
clownfish ascended the stairs
darkly, you can use something
like a grammar to figure out,
well, you know, how is
this sentence constructed.
This is a grammar for
logical predicates.
It just means that
if we run it forward,
it starts out with some sort of
abstract thing like, you know,
it's going to be a law
or some sort of set
of logical predicates.
You run it forward,
and it ends up
not with a sentence, like the
clownfish blah, blah, blah.
It ends up with a
particular law that's
relating a few particular
predicates like, you know--
sorry-- like X and Y interact
symmetrically, right?
Like, there are
things in the world.
There are X and Y. If
X interacts with Y,
Y interacts with
X. That's a law.
We run through the
grammar, we generate that.
We could run through
the grammar again,
and it will say something
completely different.
Like, of all the things
that I've related,
there are such
things as magnets.
There are metals.
And they should interact
in this way or that way.
Once we define a
grammar like that,
you can predict all sorts of
different theories, right?
I gave simplified magnetism,
but you could also
capture kinship
with a set of four
laws and several predicates.
You could capture taxonomy.
You could capture very,
very simplified psychology
of preference.
OK.
So as I said, this is another
view of theory search.
I haven't yet gotten to
the algorithmic level
of how do you actually
search for these things.
But I did want to
set up the grammar,
because it's going to be a
little bit important later on.
The grammar is just a
way of saying, you know,
you start with something.
You generate it forward
until you end up
with a particular
set of logical rules.
So, again, to phrase the
problem in a particular way
of logical inference is to say
we have the space of theories.
It's an infinite space, right?
And before I've
seen any data, there
is some probability
of the right theory
is to explain my data,
where the data can
be something like-- play with
these blogs, figure them out.
Before I've even
seen the blocks,
before I've seen anything
that I need to explain yet,
I have some sort of space
of all possible theories.
It can be all the
logical theories,
all the possible
programs in the world.
And I have some sort of
probability distribution
over which one of these are
more likely than others,
which comes from the prior.
And the prior can be
something on simplicity,
like shorter programs are
more likely, or the less free
parameters the better.
Something like that, right?
So before I've seen any data, I
can already score some programs
as being unlikely,
because they're
too long and too ungainly.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
OK.
And that's just a representation
of that in 2D space.
It's saying, like, over
here is theory space.
And the size of the
hills over 2D space
is how likely each point,
each point in theory space,
is a theory, where
theory can be,
as I said, a set of logical
laws or program or anything.
And the height of
the hill over that
is the amount of
probability you should
assign to that theory, how
much you should believe in it.
And as data comes
in, what happens
is you become more or less
certain of certain programs.
Like, suddenly you shift
probability distributions
around.
You say, oh, these things that
I didn't think were that likely,
well, the data's really pushing
me to accepting these theories.
OK?
And that's what
learning is, right?
That's the view of learning.
You just start with
particular probabilities.
You get some data.
And then you shift
that around, and you
get other probabilities.
And that's sort of a
very beautiful picture.
And the only problem with it
is that it is clearly false.
And the reason it's
false is because this
is an infinite space.
And there's no way that
you could have scored
the entire infinite space.
There's no way that what
children are doing, what adults
are doing, what
computers are doing
is to instantly shift
probability mass
over this entire space, right?
New data comes in.
They're holding in
this infinite space
and shifting exactly the
probabilities around, right?
This view of learning is
ridiculous, because, well, it's
patently absurd.
And also, people have
taken issue with it
even though it was never meant
to be the story of learning
that is happening
in the real-- well,
how should I put this,
in the real world?
Do you guys know the difference
between the computational level
and the algorithmic level when
I say something like that?
Show of hands-- who knows
about Marr's three levels?
OK.
Who doesn't know about Marr's
three levels of explanation?
OK.
The point is to say when you
try to explain the phenomenon,
you're going to give it
several levels of explanation.
You're going to give it sort
of the functional level, what
we might call the
computational level.
And then you're
going to actually say
how does this actually
get implemented
in an actual machine.
And there are many ways
of implementing things.
Like you might say, well, look,
the general problem for vision
is this, or this thing needs
to be in addition function.
These are the sort of
things I wanted to do.
But there are many
different ways
to implement that function.
Some of them are
better than others.
That's the algorithmic level.
How does this actually get
implemented in an algorithm?
Then you can implement
the algorithm
in many different
mechanistic ways.
You can go and implement it
in neurons or in silicon chips
or things like that.
There are many different
ways of implementing
a particular algorithm.
This view of, you know,
you have some theories,
you have some prior
over theories,
you shift the probabilities
around as data comes in--
that's an explanation on
the computational level.
That's not an explanation of how
we actually shift them around,
how we actually search
for these theories.
And really the
computational level
sometimes gets grief,
because people say, well,
what are you saying?
Are you saying that
Einstein somehow
had the theory of
relativity, we all
relativity, in our head?
And his process of
discovery was just
to say, well, I believe
in Newton's theory.
And I had some low
prior on relativity.
But then the data came in,
and I shifted my probability
to the theory of relativity.
That sounds not the way
people actually learn.
That doesn't sound like
the way we discover things.
That doesn't sound like the way
we come up with new theories.
That doesn't sound like the
way that children learn.
And as I said, that's not
exactly what we think.
And that's not what happens
in computers either.
That's not the
algorithmic level.
So what happens in
the algorithm level
is you actually have to
search for your theories, OK?
And this is what happens
in stochastic search
in particular.
What how does in
stochastic search--
those of you who are in
tutorial remember this--
you have some space of theories.
OK, I'm still giving you the
space of possible theories.
Each dot in theory space
is, let's say, a program.
Or in this case, it's something
like a theory in the sense
I defined it before.
It's a set of logical laws
relating these predicates
together.
OK.
So let me use--
I'm not sure you
can follow my hand
like this, right-- gaze
detection or whatever.
So theory A is, let's
say, a theory that
has three possible laws.
It says if X has a
P, P can be anything.
And Y is a P. It's the
same sort of thing.
Then they're going to interact.
The second law says if
X is P and Y is a Q,
they will interact.
It doesn't matter.
You don't have to figure
this theory out, right?
I'm just trying to give you an
example of what a theory could
be theoretically.
And they interact symmetrically.
That's one dot.
Let's call that dot number one.
That's theory A. Here is dot
number two, theory B. OK?
You as the learner, as the
stochastic search learner
in the algorithmic
level, don't have access
to the full theory space.
All you have is A. That's
where you are right now.
That's all you
have of the world.
OK.
That's how you can try
to explain the world.
And what you can do is
you can try proposing
certain changes to your theory.
You can try taking out a
law or putting in a law
or taking out a predicate,
somehow sort of messing
with your theory,
hacking with your theory
somehow, coming up
with a new theory that
gives you theory B.
It's a different point
in theory space.
And what you do then is you
compare your two theories.
You say, how well does
this predict the data?
So and so, you
give it some score.
You say, how well does this
theory predict the data?
So and so, you
give it some score.
You say, how likely is
the theory a priori?
How short is it?
How simple is it?
OK.
How short is this
theory a priori?
OK.
So you get some score
for this theory that's
based on the data in the prior.
You get some score
for this theory
based on the data in the prior.
And you basically decide which
one of these two theories
to accept.
You could either stay
with your old theory
before you proposed any changes.
Or you could decide
that, wait a minute,
that theory that I just
proposed, the new one,
is actually a bit better.
Or even if it's not better,
it's not doing that much worse,
so I'll jump to it.
OK.
That's the stochastic
part in stochastic search
or in like these
Metropolis-Hastings algorithm.
This way of sort of
jumping around in the space
is the stochastic search
I'm talking about.
You're here in theory space.
You have one theory.
You propose a change
to that theory.
And we'll get in a
second to how you propose
a change to that theory.
You propose a change.
On end up here.
You say, should I move here?
Let's check.
Is this theory doing any better?
If it's doing
better, move there.
If it's doing worse, well,
maybe still move there
depending on how much
worse it's doing.
And this process is sort of
jumping around in theory space.
Probabilistically proposing
theories and accepting them
is not that far from what
MCMC is doing or optimization
through MCMC.
Oh, sorry.
I'm clicking on this.
OK.
And you can notice that this
sort of search is somewhat
different from-- this is the
picture that Josh was showing
before--
gradient descent or
convex optimization,
the sort of thing that you
might do neural networks.
I'm not trying to suggest that
this is exactly what happens
in neural networks.
I mean, the more complicated
neural network stuff,
the energy landscape,
can be quite complicated.
And they still need to do
stochastic gradient descent.
But it doesn't look as fully
connected and as horrible
as these sort of theories
on top look like.
Because the space
there is much more--
I don't want to
say well-defined.
They're both well-defined.
But it's sort of much easier
to search through, right?
It's sort of easy to get
in these neural networks
to know where you're going
to sort of differentiate
and quickly get to your target.
You're not so much
doing this sort
of hard laborious
stochastic search.
You sort of have
this notion of, well,
it's immediately
going to be the best
direction to go in is this.
OK?
I'm just going to
do gradient decent.
I'm going to roll downhill.
And then that's some sort of
good point in neural network
land.
OK.
So how do we actually
propose alternative theories?
Well, you say, look, I have
some sort of, let's say--
let's do this.
OK.
You have some sort
of particular rule.
And then what you
do-- remember when
I said you have some sort
of grammar over theories,
kind of like a grammar in
language for those of you
who know?
The grammar describes
a particular tree
that you walk through to
end up with your theory.
What you do to propose a
change to it-- and this
is true for both these
logical theories,
but also for programs.
You go to any [INAUDIBLE].
You go to any sort of
node in that tree that
generated your program
or generated your theory,
and you change it.
You sort of re-sample from
it or, you know, cut it
and regenerate.
And then what that ends up doing
is it ends up, for example,
adding a new rule
or, for example,
changing the predicate, or
adding a new rule again,
or deleting a rule, or
deleting a predicate,
or changing a predicate,
deleting a predicate by sort
of changing predicates, deleting
rules, adding rules, adding
predicates.
I wasn't covering
the full space.
You jump around in theory land.
OK.
And this sort of dynamic of
moving around in theory land
stochastically--
one step forward,
two steps back, you
know, you don't know the
target ahead of time,
when you actually
propose something,
you proposed something new--
different learners might
take different paths
to get to the same target
ultimately starting
from an equal
state of ignorance.
You sort of propose
different theories.
You end up in different ways.
But usually, if you
get the right data,
eventually you end
up in the same spot.
These discrete moments
of sort of, you
know, faffing about and
sort of saying, well,
this rule, that rule,
that doesn't explain it.
This explains it,
doesn't explain it.
Suddenly, you propose something
that sort of clicks into place.
You say, ah, it's
not that there's
two things in the world.
There's three things
in the world, right?
It's not just
metals and plastics.
There's actually metals
and magnets and plastics.
Ah.
And suddenly, you rearrange
the data and things like that,
right?
All these things,
all these dynamics,
have something of the flavor
of children's learning.
And I didn't give
you the full spiel.
And you can go and read
some of our papers.
There's also been
other people who
have been very
interested in sort
of looking at the dynamics
of stochastic search,
how well it predicts
what children are doing.
Among them, I'll
just mention people
like Liz Bonawitz and
Stephanie Denison,
and also Tom Griffiths,
and finally Alison Gopnik.
So I also have TED
speaker on my side.
And not just any TED speaker--
it's Laura's former advisor.
So at that point, it's a good
point to hand it off to Laura
and see what she has
to say about this.
But a midpoint summary is to
say theories are useful, right?
I think Josh has already
convinced you of that.
We want theories.
The problem is that they
define these rich structured
complicated landscapes
much more rich, much more
complicated than
anything that you might
find in the neural network.
Well, yes.
And it's hard to search for
these rich, complicated, fully
connected landscapes, like
the space of all programs
or the space of all
possible logic theories.
And the way to
sort through it is
stochastic search, which can
be horribly slow and wrong
and things like that.
But the claim is something
like, what are you
going to do, right?
I mean, we want
these rich theories.
Rich theories define
rich landscapes.
And you just have to
get away right now
with stochastic search.
Our algorithm solution
for these spaces
are stochastic search
in that rich landscape.
And, well, why
shouldn't that apply
to what children are doing?
So here with a why not is Laura.
LAURA SCHULZ: I
think I have one.
I'm hooked up, right?
OK.
So when I first
engaged in this debate
with Tomer, I was stuck
on this kind of a thought
that what's going to
happen here is-- in which,
following an eloquent
exposition of a former model,
attendant experiments,
and quantitative data,
Laura proceeds to
wave her hands around.
Someone was asking
about intuitions.
And I just had this strong
compelling intuition
this was completely wrong.
But mainly, I was
puzzled as to why I was
stuck on this archaic locution.
What was I doing with
this "in which" situation?
And it occurred
to me the reason I
was stuck on this particular
locution is that I was thinking
of a particular story
that nicely illustrates
exactly what I think the problem
is with stochastic search.
It's from a classic in
developmental literature,
the stories, of course, A.
A. Milne and Winnie the Pooh.
And this is the particular
problem of "in which"
Christopher Robin and Pooh
and all go on an expedition
to the North Pole.
And so they're
organizing a search.
And like Tomer's algorithms,
they don't actually
know where the North Pole is.
And it turns out, as Christopher
Robin confides in a moment
to rabbit, they also don't know
what the North Pole is, also
like Tomer's algorithms.
But they do something
about the terrain.
And they know
something about search.
You gather all the
friends and relations.
And you engage in an iterative
process over and over
and over again
until you succeed,
and you find yourself
at the North Pole.
And Eeyore is a little
bit skeptical about this.
He says, well, you can
call this you know,
expo-whatever or
gathering nuts in May.
It's all the same to him.
And at the of the
day, I actually
think Christopher Robin
and colleagues here
have a certain set of advantages
over Tomer and colleagues.
And that is that it is
a Hundred Acre Wood.
And so if the North
Pole's really there,
and they engage in
that process, and they
have all of rabbits
friends and relations,
they probably will find it.
But it also turns out that,
unlike Tomer and colleagues,
they do know something about
what they're searching for.
Now, they're wrong about this.
But nonetheless, I think they
access an important constraint
on the search
process and actually
helps them out quite a lot.
So that's what I'm going to
try to talk to you about today.
So here are the issues
with stochastic search.
I think there are two big ones.
Grant everything--
grant grammar,
grant prior knowledge,
grant templates,
grant a bias towards simplicity.
The problem with an
infinite search space
is infinite is a very, very,
very big space to search.
It's a very big space to search.
And children seem to do
remarkably well with it.
So I'm going to, I guess, give
you a toy fictional example.
I'm going to give you
a non-fiction example
from my child.
We were riding on an airplane.
She was about 3 and
1/2 at the time.
And she knows a lot
about airplanes.
She has a lot of folk
physics, prior knowledge
about airplanes.
And she also knows
a lot about phones.
She's had a lot of
experience of phones.
But nothing in her
prior knowledge
predicted the
announcement that you
have to turn off your cell phone
when you fly a plane, right?
So this was surprising.
And she immediately said,
well, I know the answer.
I know why you have to do that.
And I know that she
doesn't know anything
about radio transmission
or government bureaucracy.
So I said, how do you know?
Why do you think?
And she said, well, because
when the plane takes off,
it's too noisy to hear.
You know, that example
is not especially clever
or especially adorable.
But what is really, really
interesting about that answer
is that although it is
wrong-- it's even wrong
as to the causal direction--
it is a good wrong
answer compared
to all of the other
things that are
consistent with her prior
knowledge and the grammar
of her intuitive theories
that she didn't say.
She didn't say, because
airplanes are made of metal
and so are phones.
Because airplanes
fly over the Earth,
and the Earth has phones.
Because airplanes are
big and phones are small.
Because airplanes-- her
grandfather lives in Ohio
and has led her to believe that
everything is made in Ohio.
Because airplanes and phones
are both made in Ohio.
Infinite is a very big space.
There are a lot
of things that you
could say consistent
with prior knowledge
where you're making
random changes
in your intuitive theories
that are not even wrong.
They're not even wrong.
And so the real
question is, how did she
converge at a good wrong
answer, at an answer
that, although it is
wrong, makes sense?
It isn't just, I
think, a toy problem.
But here is the problem.
There are innumerable
logical constitutive
causal and relational hypotheses
consistent with the grammar
of intuitive theories.
How do we so rapidly, literally
between the announcement
and the next thing
out of our mouths,
converge on ones that,
if they were true,
might explain the data?
They might not be true.
But if they were,
they could work.
They could solve problems.
And that I think is the
really hard mystery.
And again, it's not
just a toy problem.
Modeling even relatively
simple well-understood problems
takes time.
I would often come
across Josh's students
wandering in the hallways.
And I say, what are you doing?
They're like, oh, I'm
waiting for my model to run.
I'm like, waiting
for your model?
Computers are really fast.
They're fast
information processing.
What is it doing?
Well, it turns out it's
generating a lot of answers
that aren't even wrong.
That's what it's doing, right?
It's spending a
lot of time sitting
around sifting through things
that aren't even right.
Iterations are spent
searching in hopeless places.
And this is true of some of
the best and the brightest.
This was like a fantastic
NIPS paper, a major advance.
It's a probabilistic
graphics program.
And it's solving the really
deep theory problem of CAPTCHAs.
So it's trying to figure
out in this case--
but it doesn't just
do-- in fairness-- well,
let me return to that.
Let me show you what it does do.
There's a rectangle over there.
It wants to be able to figure
out what is in that space.
And it wants to model it.
It wants to find a rectangle
in the lower left-hand corner
of a scene.
So what does it do?
It generates pixels
all over the map
until it finds the rectangle.
And I saw this in [INAUDIBLE].
And I said, why is
it looking all--
can it at least
confine its search
to the lower left-hand corner?
But, of course, the
algorithm doesn't know
from lower left-hand corners.
It's a powerful algorithm.
If you wanted to
solve a CAPTCHA,
you could do-- see look at it.
It's all over the place.
Now, this is a virtue.
And, yeah, it converges.
And that's just great, right?
But why doesn't it search
in lower left-hand corner?
Well, the answer
is it doesn't know
from lower left-hand corners.
And it's a feature, not a bug,
that it doesn't know from this.
Because that means
it doesn't just
solve CAPTCHAs, which you
can do with edge detection.
It can find, you know,
objects in the road.
And it can do all
kinds of other things
that I'm sure Josh
and Vikash would
be happy to talk to you about.
It's a pretty general thing.
But it's not constrained.
And that's a feature.
But the interesting
thing about humans,
including human
children, is they are
both flexible and constrained.
They can both solve a
whole bunch of problems,
and they can converge on
them very quickly, right?
Whereas, here, it trades off.
And, again, that is
a simpler problem.
That is a square and
a bunch of pixels.
The kind of learning we're
talking about when we're
trying to talk about theory
generation or real world
learning is a really, really,
really, really big space.
So one problem is
just how are you
going to get at least to
answers that, if they were true,
might work?
But if one problem is that the
theory space is really big,
the other problem is that human
learners are not that dumb.
We have a lot of knowledge.
And we have a lot of knowledge
that these algorithms are not
making use of.
And the question is, why not?
And is there any way
that we could develop
models that did make use of it?
In particular, we know a
lot about our problems.
Our problems are
actually our friends.
We know about our
problems and our goals.
And we know about our
problems well before we
can solve those problems.
An abstract representation
of what the solution might
look like, what it
ought to do, what
the criteria it's
trying to satisfy are,
could help constrain
and guide the search.
It matters about
it though, not just
that she had prior knowledge
about airplanes and about
phones, but that she
had prior knowledge
that the problem
she was solving was
an unpredicted incompatibility
between airplanes and phones.
You have to turn one off
when the other is going on.
That's information that's
not in her general background
knowledge.
It's about the particular
problem that she has.
And the question
is how could you
use that to make good proposals
and make better proposals?
So the proposal I
have is that when
you know something about
what you're looking for,
then that can help you find it.
And this is the
kind of knowledge
that Christopher
Robin and colleagues
had that Tomer and
colleagues did not.
They at least eventually decided
that what they were looking for
was, of course, a pole.
They know what poles are.
Therefore, when
they find a pole,
they can be quite confident
that here they are.
And this is a good candidate
solution to their problem.
That solution is wrong,
but at least it's wrong.
OK.
So the argument
here, which I'm going
to try to get
slightly more precise,
is that the form of the problem
as an input to the algorithm
should increase the probability
that proposes useful ideas.
And you can consider this
even in the simplest form
in the kind of information that
is contained in our question
words.
So I think it's an interesting
feature about human cognition
that we have a very, very
small handful of question
words, which we use to
query the entire universe.
And you know what?
Those question words do
a lot of work for us.
When I tell you I'm asking
a question about who,
you might propose that
we ought to be looking
for some kind of
answer that's something
like a social network.
And a social network might
be more likely as an answer
than a 2D map.
Whereas, if I ask you a question
about where, well, you really
do want to consider 2D maps.
If I'm asking when, you're
talking about a time line
answer.
If I ask you a why question,
maybe it's a causal network.
And if I'm asking
you a how question,
maybe it's a circuit
diagram, right?
You don't know anything about
the content at this point.
I could be asking you anything.
But I ask you who was
Christopher Columbus,
and you answer 1492.
That's the kind of thing that
our algorithms are doing.
That's not even wrong, right?
It's consistent with
your prior knowledge.
And it's the kind
of thing Watson does
as good [INAUDIBLE] solutions.
But it's not what children do.
It's not what children do.
I think that the issue
is that this is actually
a friendly amendment, right?
Because in what we have
shown time and again--
by we I mean not me, but
computational modeling folks--
is that we can use
lots of information
out there for hypothesis
evaluation, right?
Once we have a theory
and we have the data,
we can select and use this
information and say, well,
does it answer the
problem or not, right?
Does it improve?
Does it make better predictions?
So we use this kind of
information that we have.
Even formally, we can
say that we can use
it to select among hypotheses.
We can use information about
the structural form of problem
to represent them.
The question is, can we use
the same kind of information
to constrain the search space?
And it's easy for me to say.
I don't have to do that, right?
But it's the kind of proposal
that I think is missing.
Because we have rich constraints
that go far, far, far
beyond our question words.
The kinds of
problems that we have
and the criteria
for solving them
derive from all
kinds of sources.
We try to solve different
kinds of problems--
navigation in some cases,
explanation in other cases.
And some of those
are epistemic ends.
I want to persuade
you of something.
I want to instruct
you in something.
I want to deceive
you in some ways.
But we also have all kinds
of non-epistemic goals.
I want to impress you.
I want to soothe you.
I want to entertain you.
Each of these goals is
actually a constraint
on what is going to
count as the solution.
Our goals are innumerable.
But there are only
a small handful
of ways you can
solve any given goal.
So when you're dealing with
an infinite search space,
having a goal, having
a problem, actually
could act as a constraint on
how you search for the solution.
And it is an interesting
feature of human cognition
that our goals can
be noble or venial.
They can be
impressive or trivial.
And it may not
matter with respect
to the solution we have.
We have analytic logic,
because the medieval monks
wanted to find incontrovertible
proof for the existence of God.
We don't hold onto
their goal, but we
hold onto their solution.
We are here in the East
Coast of Massachusetts,
because of the search for
the West Indies, right?
So our goals act as
constraints on the solution
and on the search process.
And the importance
of our goals may
be that they do exactly
that, that they help leverage
some new search in a way that
at least helps us make progress.
So the argument here is
instead of stochastic search,
that we have--
I don't call it goal oriented.
I call it goal constrained now--
goal-constrained hypothesis
generation.
And the idea here
is that at least we
know something about
where we want to go.
Now, this is not
a total argument
against stochastic search.
It's just a way of getting
stochastic search into a much
smaller search space, right?
Once you know what things count,
then you can do everything
Tomer says you do.
I actually agree with him.
But you don't want to do
it over all possibilities,
because you know a lot
more than that, right?
You know what kinds of
things are going to count.
You should do it over that
space, not over-- should
look in the left-hand corner.
Then you can iterate
all the pixels you want.
But if the thing's on
the left-hand corner,
that's where you
ought to be looking.
I'm going to give you a
corollary to this, which
is if you don't have any idea
what the search space is,
you are going to
resort to an extremely
inefficient, extremely
frustrating search
and, actually, the kinds
of conditions under which I
think human beings quit.
So I will give you an example
from my personal experience,
as Jessica Sommerville knows.
Because we were trying to
get my child's booster seat--
because children now
need booster seats until
they're 14--
re-attached from
my plane flight.
Couldn't do it, right?
One thing goes down,
two things go up.
It's a spatial problem.
We spent 10 minutes,
two PhDs, on it--
threw the thing out
and just had her ride
in the bottom of the booster
seat without the top.
If I have 1,000 piece puzzle and
I have to find a puzzle piece,
people who are good
at puzzles know
before they find that
piece something about what
it's going to look like.
Like, OK, well, the edge
has to be angled like this.
It has to have a concavity
here and a convexity there.
And that's what I'm looking for.
Me-- soon as I look
away from the piece,
I have no idea what
I'm looking for.
And so I do what Tomer would do.
I do a stochastic search
over all the puzzles,
And with 1,000 pieces
and many permutations,
that is not a good
way to solve a puzzle.
As a result, I never
do puzzles, right?
As entertainment, I
just don't understand.
But if you do know, it's
very satisfying, right?
You know what
you're looking for.
And now you can constrain
your search space
much more effectively to
those kinds of things.
Indeed, when I say we
are smarter than that,
human beings know.
We have metacognitive principles
around these kinds of things,
right?
This knowledge is
in human minds,
what it might mean
for us to think
that a problem is tractable.
What does that word mean, right?
Sometimes it means we have
the financial resources
or the technology
to carry it off.
But often, it means we
have a well-posed problem.
We don't know the
answer, but we know
what the answer needs to do.
We know what the answer
needs to look like.
We have criteria for
what would count.
At least we have a precise
enough representation
of the problem to effectively
and efficiently guide
the search.
And I think that's
the kind of thing
we would ideally like our
models and algorithms to have.
At that point, we may have
to bounce around a lot.
But we're bouncing in a
pretty well-defined space.
So to the degree
that this is true,
it actually explains a lot of
otherwise peculiar features
of human cognition.
For instance, we
had this weird sense
that we're on the
right track, right?
Well, what does it mean
to be on the right track?
It surely doesn't mean you're
better at explaining the data,
right?
You may be nowhere
close to having
an answer that makes better
predictions or gets it right.
But you're like, oh, that's
a really good idea, you know?
You get excited.
Or you're like, no,
that's a non-answer.
What does it mean?
It might mean that
at least it fits
the abstract form of solution.
If it were true, it might work.
We can tell our students
in an undergraduate class
that that was a great
idea even when we know
it's been disproven, right?
So it's actually false.
It doesn't explain.
It's just not true.
We still think it's a great
idea in virtue of what?
Not it's fit to the data, right?
Not how well it's
predicting things.
It's actually false
and still good.
What could that
possibly mean, right?
It must mean there's
some other constraint
on hypothesis generation
that we are sensitive to.
So I want to suggest that
there are actually two
constraints for our hypotheses.
One is how well they fit
prior knowledge and data.
That's the one we
know something about.
That is, for instance, truth.
But Stephen Colbert
in his infinite wisdom
proposed something else.
He said, well, we're also
sensitive to this thing called
truthiness, right?
You know, like how
good the story sounds,
how good the argument.
And of course, in
politics, you know,
he makes massive and
effective fun of this.
But I think this is a feature
of human cognition, not a bug.
I think it is extremely
important that we can generate
ideas that are truthy, right?
Because they're plausible.
They're interesting.
They're informative.
They tell good story.
They may be false, but it
could be worse than false.
It could be not even false.
So I want to make an
important point here.
Generating new ideas is not just
about Einstein versus Newton.
And it's not about going from
an undifferentiated concept
of heat and temperature to
a modern scientific one.
It's just about radical
conceptual change.
This is the stuff of
ordinary everyday thought.
It is our ability
to reliably make up
new relevant answers to
basically any ad hoc question.
The answers may be trivial.
They may be false.
But they are genuinely new.
And that we didn't have them
until we thought of them,
they're genuinely made up.
We didn't learn them from
evidence or testimony.
And they answer the question.
They're not non-sequiturs.
And I think this is important.
And this is only
possible if we can
use the form of our
problems to guide search.
So let me give you
a few examples.
What's a good name
for a theater company?
None of you know.
You haven't thought about
that problem before.
But now you're
thinking about it.
Well, what's a good name
for a theater company?
How do you get stripes
on peppermints?
This is not a problem you
walked in thinking about.
None of you are working on this
as your independent project.
But you can think about it.
And you already know
enough, knowing nothing
about theater and nothing about
peppermints maybe, to know what
the constraints,
what counts, right?
That's the kind of
information you already have.
It's not prior knowledge
about theater companies
or peppermints.
It's part knowledge about what's
going to work for a solution.
So for instance, you know that
McDonald's is a nonstarter.
And [INAUDIBLE] or whatever
is also not a good name
for a theater company.
You know that getting
strips on peppermints
you don't want to do it
with a spatter [INAUDIBLE]..
You don't want to just
spray things at it, right?
Because that wouldn't
even count as a solution.
That's not the kind of
thing you're looking for.
You're looking for something
more like fresh ink.
It's new.
It's novel.
It's familiar.
It makes some reference.
You're looking for something
more like a pendulum approach,
which at least could
generate periodicity.
I'm sure they don't use
a pendulum to spray paint
peppermints.
So are you.
But it's not a
bad answer, right?
So is there any evidence
that kids can do this,
that information
contained in only
that strict form of
the problem can help
learners converge on solutions?
We wanted to find out.
So I'm going to show a
little baby attempt to start
getting at this problem.
We gave kids a machine.
And we gave kids some things
that could work the machine.
And the machine had
two visual effects.
You could make a ball appear to
flow up and down on that screen
there.
Or you could make the
ball appear at the bottom
and then flash up
at the top, right?
Because we put a
computer behind, right?
So woo, the ball is
moving continuously,
or the ball is
moving discretely.
And the affordance,
as you might note,
are also continuous
or discrete, right?
There's a rolly
ball, or there's this
peg that you can move back
and forth continuously.
Or there's a peg you
can pull in and out,
or a drawer you can
pull in and out.
So there's continuous and
discrete affordances and also
continuous and discrete effects.
So we also had an auditory
tone that varied continuously
and an auditory tone that
went from high to low.
Everyone got it?
And we just showed the
children all the parts
that connected to the machine.
And then we showed
the kids the effects,
but we had hid the affordances.
And we said, well, which
part made the ball go?
And we asked them either
about the visual or auditory
affordance?
They'd seen no covariation
data, prior knowledge- you know,
agnostic about all of this.
And the question
is, well, would they
say, well, I'm trying
to solve a problem
about a continuous effect.
I should use a
continuous affordance.
I'm trying to solve a problem
about a discrete effect.
I should use a
discrete affordance.
Would they use something
about the form of the problem
to answer the solution if they
knew nothing else about it?
So there's no fact of
the matter here, right?
Because, obviously, we're not
using either of these really.
But the prediction was
that they would indeed
make this kind of mapping.
And they did so.
Now, what you might worry
about was that, well,
there is no fact of the matter.
So they're just doing some kind
of cross-modal mapping, right?
If you don't have a way
to answer the problem,
they're just saying
something like, well, you
know, this has this
property, so does this.
Let me go ahead and make a
mapping from one to the other.
It's a weird kind of
cross-modal mapping.
Because, usually,
you integrate things
that are in a single stimulus
actually contained together,
like the sound of
a ball dropping
and the sight of
a ball dropping,
not two different things.
But maybe it's something
kind of like that.
So if they're actually
using the form of a problem,
then if you change
the problems, they
should generate
different solutions.
So what we did in the second
experiment is we said--
oh.
Yeah.
So what we did here is
we showed the children
the continuous visual
stimuli, and then we
asked them to generate the
continuous auditory stimuli.
OK.
So all of these
are now continuous.
They could still just go ahead
and make the continuous map.
But if you represent the
problem as changing from visual
to audition, that feels like
a discrete problem, right?
You're completely
changing modalities.
So now at this case,
you might expect
the kids to resist making
just the continuous mapping
if they're using something
about the kind of problem
they have to constrain how
they search for the solution.
Now, again, there's no
real right answer here.
But what you see is the
kids shifted their responses
in response to this.
So this is just a
tiny bit of suggestion
that when there's no
differentiating prior knowledge
and there's no
differentiating evidence,
children take into account
what kind of problem
they're trying to solve,
and what the information is,
and the problem itself that
can help constrain their search
for a solution.
I'm going to give you
another example for some more
recent work by Pedro
Tsividis in our lab.
He varied the
dynamics of a scene.
He had here some bugs.
And in one scene,
those bugs in green,
they varied periodically.
So they just went from
having very few spots
to having a whole lot
of spots to having
a very few spots to having
a whole lot of spots, right?
That's what these green bugs do.
And the other bugs just
got faster over time.
So those longer
vectors are supposed
to be indicating the bugs are
getting faster continuously.
And then he said,
well, you know,
here are some bugs
in these rooms.
And I have two kinds
of lights in the room.
One set of lights looks
like those on top.
The other set of lights looks
like those on the bottom.
Can you tell me which lights
are responsible for the behavior
of which bugs?
Again, a sort of very
similar kind of problem.
No fact to the matter that
if children can represent
something about the
abstract form of the problem
and use that to constrain
their search for the solution,
then the periodic lights should
reflect the periodic change
in the bug's behavior.
The continuous light should
reflect the continuous change
in the bug's behavior.
We are, of course, not using
the words periodic or continuous
with us or anything like that.
They have to pull
that out and say,
this is the kind
of problem it is.
This is a feature of
a possible solution.
Let's go ahead and
make that mapping.
And indeed, the kids are
doing that well above chance.
And obviously, in
this case, we're
giving the kids some
possible solutions.
They're not generating
it whole cloth.
But minimally, it's
a different way
of thinking about
problems and search.
They're not using most of
our sort of traditional ways
of figuring it out.
They're just using something
about the kind of problem
they have and what's
available in the problem
to help sort out the solution.
So is this analogical
reasoning, right?
It feels kind of an analogy.
But it's a funny
kind of analogy.
Because what it
isn't is a mapping
between a known problem and a
known solution to a new problem
and a new solution.
It's rather a mapping
from the kind of problem
you have to the kind
of solution you have.
It's using, again, the
problem or the query itself
as your friend.
It has information in it about
how it wants to be solved.
How are you going to
use that to solve it?
And, again, the
virtue being that
even if your answer is wrong,
if it were true, it would work.
So the argument
also, of course, is
that this applies to any
possible goal we might have
including those cases where
it's just not at all obvious how
an analogy would apply.
So what is a good name for
a theater company, right?
You're using
something about what
would count as a solution to
constraint something about what
you think would
be a good answer.
But there's not an easy
way to tell that story
as analogical reasoning.
So their argument
is children seem
to have data independent
criteria for the evaluation
of hypotheses.
And these criteria extend beyond
simplicity, grammaticality,
or compatibility
with prior knowledge.
They consider the extent to
which a hypothesis fulfills
the abstract goals of a
solution of a problem,
not just the degree to
which it fits the data.
And I will suggest that
this is maybe deeply part
of an important mystery
of human cognition, which
is-- our most powerful learners
spend a lot of their time
doing something that has defied
most of our best attempts
to explain it, which is
they've spent a lot of time,
many hours a day, just
pretending and making up
stories.
Stories have some
interesting properties.
They do not have
to be true, right?
They don't have to fit
the world or fit the data.
But they do have to set up
a problem and a solution
that, if true, would
solve the problem.
Most of play has that.
It is not at all obvious why
you would think it was important
that you want to balance a
twisty on the top of the candle
stick in order to
shoot pee through it.
But it's a problem.
And guess what?
If you can set up the problem
and find the solution,
you've just accessed a
really important ability
about setting up problems
and setting up solutions
that, if they worked, would
solve that kind of problem.
And, of course,
imagination, most
of our narratives,
most of our fictions,
have at least those
sets of properties.
So I'm going to go
ahead and stop there.
[APPLAUSE]
TOMER ULLMAN: OK.
So if you remember the structure
we said at the beginning,
there will now be
a short rebuttal.
And then Laura will give
an even shorter summary,
and then the free for all.
So most of you are probably
thinking all sorts of ways
that Laura is wrong.
But wait, let me get
through it first,
and then see if I
didn't cover something.
But, actually, my response
to this, to all of what
Laura's said, is not you're
wrong, but you're right.
So you're right, Laura.
You're right.
Other people in the audience
who think that stochastic search
by itself--
if you have some sort of
infinite theory space that
was supposed to account
for all possible problems
and for any new
problem what you did
was to just completely
at random try
to search through that space
anew, then that wouldn't work--
that's fine.
And I agree that there's
something inherently
wrong about an algorithm
that can take some problem,
like why these two blocks
are sticking together,
and say, well, maybe it's
because the moon is bigger
than a piece of cheese, right?
Like, as Laura said, it just
seems like it's not even wrong.
Or maybe it's because people
have more than two children
on average.
No.
And there's also
something wrong.
Laura didn't quite get to this
or maybe not emphasize it.
But she emphasizes it
sometimes, which is
there's something wrong about--
well, she did a little,
but-- an algorithm that
makes sort of dumb proposals.
Dumb proposals of
all sorts of things--
things like you try to explain
something in theory space,
and you say, well, maybe it's
because of X. And you check it,
and it's not X. And you
say, oh well, oh well.
Maybe it's because of X, right?
There's something wrong
about stochastic search.
Although, I have to say, Laura,
you have an eight-year-old.
And, you know, when we gave this
first, I had a two-year-old.
And I actually think maybe
it's X, maybe it's X,
maybe it's X is not such
a crazy way of describing
what two-year-olds are doing.
LAURA SCHULZ: Well, [INAUDIBLE].
So, you know, like,
what if there's noise?
TOMER ULLMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
OK.
But I do want to give
an actual response.
So, you know, I think I have
some responses for Laura.
And these are responses that,
importantly, you know, they'll
try to address what
Laura is saying.
They'll try to take
it into account.
They'll try to give new answers
to it that will importantly
leave her unhappy.
So what I'm going to try
to do is take a page out
of Hannibal Barca at the Battle
of Cannae and try to envelop.
So I'm going to highlight
of work by other people.
From one direction is work
by Steve Piantadosi, which
is about making these, you
know, algorithmic search part
of the problem,
whether it's too slow,
students are wandering
around the halls
doing nothing waiting
for it to converge.
What if we just did it
really, really fast?
Another way to address
this is to say,
what if we made
actually good proposals?
OK.
The problem of making proposals
that are just ridiculous-- what
if we made proposals
that actually take
the data into
account a little bit
or the previous data, the stuff
that we're trying to explain?
Another way to address
what Laura is saying
is to say, well, maybe we
can make better primitives.
And better primitives mean that
your search space is actually
more confined to the
right sort of things.
And finally, I'm going to
highlight some new thoughts
by myself about ad hoc spaces
and how we might construct them
to get at this
problem of this thing,
like how would you come up with
a new name for theater company
or a name for a new
theater company?
So I'll go through
these somewhat fast.
You're welcome to come and
talk about any of them.
And I'll point you
to the people who
are actually doing the work,
which I've said before.
So let's see.
This is just sort
of the rebuttal.
One of the rebuttals
is to say, well, here's
this work by Steve Piantadosi,
which is, you know,
introspection is really
actually a poor guide.
So when [INAUDIBLE] was giving
that beautiful example of cell
phones, why you have to
shut them off on airplanes,
you say, oh, and she
came up with this example
that it's not true.
But if it were true,
it would be nice.
Well, maybe she went through
a billion other things
before she came up with that?
Laura's like, she
did it like that.
But we don't have a good sense
for what is actually fast,
what is actually slow.
And there might be a case where
we don't actually introspect
about a lot of things.
The things that bubble
up into consciousness
that you might actually
accept or reject
rely on actually a
ton of other proposals
that they don't even bubble
up into introspection
that you're making
very quickly and just
rejecting even before that.
And Steve came up with this
really interesting way.
You guys have probably
heard about deep learning
and the sort of
the GPU revolution
for deep learning
and things like that.
So the point is if
instead of we use
CPUs we would use
graphical processing units,
then we can make stochastic
search algorithms in parallel
in some cases.
And once you can make
them in parallel,
then you can put them on a GPU.
And once you put
them on a GPU, a GPU
is sort of a way
of taking something
that's supposed to be a CPU.
And instead of
having a CPU that can
do something sort of
complicated on a sort of task,
you can do a lot of really
simple tasks in parallel
very fast.
So if you could
make that proposal,
that thing I said
before-- take a theory,
make a change to it--
if you could make that
into the sort of thing that
you could put on a GPU,
then you can make a
ton of those proposals
very quickly in parallel.
And that's sort of
what he figured out how
to do for a bunch of spaces.
It's much faster than the CPU.
And the main advantage is
that it's also much cheaper.
And you can cram a
whole bunch of together.
And you can get to
something like--
I forget the exact numbers.
You can make like a million
of these theories proposals
a second.
And that's just with
today's technology, right?
We don't know what's
coming around the corner
a few years from now.
You know, Steve plus
GPUs is awesome.
And you could think of it
like these various problems
like you're trying to fit these
data points on the bottom.
Can people see that?
This is sort of a
classic problem.
You have some data points.
You're trying to fit
a polynomial to it.
And you're trying to say,
well, how will we do that?
The truth is there's a lot of
very clever ways of doing that.
But let's assume
that you're even
doing random search
in polynomial space--
not the sort of
thing you want to do.
Those of you who have
been to the tutorial,
I mentioned that if you
have an actual better
way than stochastic search,
you should probably do that.
But suppose you
didn't know and you
wanted to do stochastic search.
You could still do a
million moves a second
and quickly converge on
something like that line
that you see.
OK.
And that line is actually
taken from, I think,
Galileo Galilei's data for
how things slide on a hill.
I'm not Galileo Galilei
sat around and said,
maybe it's x to the square,
maybe it's x to the 2.1,
maybe it's x to the 2.3,
maybe it's x to the
2, and then finally
converged like after a
million moves to that.
That's not exactly
scientific discovery.
But for a lot of
everyday thinking,
you might actually be
proposing things very fast
and rejecting them.
OK.
That's Steve.
Some things from Owen Lewis
about making maybe smarter
proposals-- and this gets at
that point of, like, maybe it's
an x, maybe not.
So I suppose that I'm trying
to teach you a concept.
OK.
I'm trying to teach you
a particular concept.
I'm going to give you
some positive examples
of the concept.
OK?
This is the sort of thing
that psychologists really
like to study.
OK?
So this is a room--
no, Roomba's an actual thing.
Blick gets overused.
Can someone give
me a nonsense term?
This is a Jabberwock.
OK?
I'm going to give you another
example of a Jabberwock.
Who thinks they know
what Jabberwocks are?
You have some sense of
what a Jabberwock is?
OK.
Huh, that's also a Jabberwock.
Wait a minute.
OK.
The sense that I had for
maybe what a Jabberwock is
is maybe not that great.
That's a Jabberwock.
OK.
And you might think at
this point, well, fine.
Jabberwocks are either squares
of any color or red circles.
Or maybe they're
squares or circles.
I don't know exactly.
You're building up
some sort of theory
for that concept,
which can be described
in something like a grammar
for your current hypothesis.
You might say it's
either a red circle,
or it's the square of any color.
OK.
And that's sort of your
grammar for these concepts.
And now you could sort of
change that grammar, right?
You could sort of excise
these nodes and that tree
to come up with new things.
Why would you want to
come up with new things?
Because, look,
that's a Jabberwock.
OK.
I just gave you a new example.
It's something you
didn't know before.
It's sort of confounding
with your theory.
You have to come up with
a new theory on the fly.
OK?
Theory-- again, used in a
very, very minimal sense here.
But if you accept that this
is something like a theory,
you have to come up with a
new theory for explaining
why that's a Jabberwock and all
the other things that you've
seen are Jabberwocks.
What is a bad idea?
A bad idea is to just cut
and generate randomly, right?
You might come up with
something like it's a triangle
or something like that.
But you might come up with,
well, maybe it's a square.
No, we already did that.
Well, maybe it's, you
know, just triangles.
Maybe it's just a square.
Like, you could
spend all this time
not taking into account your
previous theory and the fact
that your new
example had something
to do with triangles, something
to do with red triangles.
You want to be able to
make proposals that take
into account this new data.
Does everyone understand
what the problem
we're trying to get at is?
So what Owen has done is to sort
of take these stochastic search
algorithms and say, if you
get a new piece of data that
contradicts, that sort of
interferes with what you had
before, how would
you make proposals
that must take into
account this new data?
I'm going to recut and generate.
But I'm going to
identify the places
in my theory that would take
into account this new piece
of data.
And I'm going to make
smarter proposals.
They might still be wrong.
And there's better and
worse ways of doing this.
It's still going to be a
randomized search and theory
space.
But it's at least going to take
into account this new data.
OK.
And that's just-- I'm
afraid I don't have time.
But, look, it works.
And it's much better
than just bouncing around
completely around random
as you might guess.
Another response, this
work by Eyal Dechter.
Let me skip over this
for a little bit.
This is work Eyal
Dechter, which is to say,
what if you wanted to use
better and better primitives?
OK.
So before we have this notion
of you're just bouncing around
in theory space, you're
making all sorts of notions,
let me put it this way.
Suppose that you're searching
through the entire space
of programs.
OK?
And the only thing that
you had to work with
is something like that lambda
expression before, right?
You didn't have the notion of
plus, minus, multiplication,
sine waves, things like that.
And you're trying to figure out
something about an equation.
And you work through it.
And there's a way of doing it.
There's a way of, like,
generating functions
that rely on other
functions that
rely on other functions in
the complicated way that will
give you the plus function.
OK?
And you do that.
And then you generate a lot.
And you somehow manage to
find out the sinus function.
And you finally figure
out that this function
you're trying to describe
is sinus x plus sinus y.
Let's say something like that.
OK?
The exact example
doesn't matter.
But you worked really hard,
and you figured that out.
Now, you get a new example.
And underneath the
hood, it's actually just
sinus x minus sinus y.
Or let's say it's sinus y plus
sinus z or something like that.
And now you start
all over again.
You're like, fine.
OK, lambda something,
something, something.
Like, if you could only use
the fact that you've already
discovered the sign
function, you've
already discovered plus and
minus and things like that,
and now when you come to try
and explain a new problem,
you actually have a lot
of previous knowledge.
OK?
So when you're trying to
describe why airplanes take off
and how they do
that, you're actually
going to rely on
previous knowledge.
You're not going to search
through your entire theory
space starting from nowhere.
You're going to
rely on primitives
before that have been useful.
So you might notice that
actually plus and minus
and sines and things like that
and cosine and exponentiation
are really useful.
Let's save those as primitives.
So that next time that we make
random proposals in theory
space, you can think
of it of making
like a whole bunch of moves
at once that were useful.
OK.
Like, a whole bunch
of stuff at once
that was useful that
shows up all the time--
you want to make that again.
OK?
So I try that, for example.
And the examples that we
gave in theory space--
like you might find out that
actually a lot of theories
use transitivity, or a lot of
theories use reflection, right?
In the particular magnet
case, if X attracts Y,
then Y will attract
X, in general,
the law of if X
blahs Y, then Y will
blah X, that turns out to be
useful in a lot of domains
if only there was a way
of reusing them, right?
There is.
And what Eyal was doing
was to basically use
an explanation compression
algorithm, the EC algorithm.
And what it does is it tries
to encapsulate useful concepts.
And he used it on a
whole bunch of stuff.
One of the nice
domains he used it on
was these circuit diagrams.
Have any of you actually had
to solve circuit diagrams?
This is the sort of stuff
that people at MIT do.
You're given a particular
input-output function.
And again, like I
said, under the hood
it might be something like
you're just told something
like here's X and Y, OK?
X and Y can each be 1 or 0.
OK?
And now I'm going to give you
combinations of values of X
and Y and what that spits out.
OK.
So X and Y are both 1--
light turns on.
X and Y are both 0--
X is 1, Y is 0--
light turns off.
OK.
And you're trying to find
out some sort of circuit that
will explain this behavior,
some sort of combination logic
gates, like ANDs and ORs and
NANDs and things like that.
OK?
Do people sort of understand
the problem for these circuits?
And you can get a long list of
things, X, Y, Z, T, some sort
of complicated behavior.
You might not even
get the full behavior.
And you're trying to find
sort of the minimal set
of logical predicates, or
in this case circuits, that
will explain that behavior.
And now suppose
that you only have
the gate NAND to work with.
Do people know what NAND is?
OK.
It's a sort of logic gate.
It's a very simple logic
gate that you can build up
all the other logic gates from.
But it will take you a while
to build up AND from NAND or OR
from NAND.
But you can do it.
And so what he did was,
and his colleagues, they
started out sort of
giving this algorithm
a lot of different problems.
Like, here's a bunch of circuit
diagrams that you need to solve
or circuit problems that you
need to find the diagram for.
What the algorithm was
doing was that each time it
solved a problem
or set of problems,
it would go back and look,
huh, which parts of this
can I encapsulate, right?
Which parts of this can
I sort of use again?
I can carve off a chunk of
something that was useful.
And now, when I
make a new proposal,
I'm not going to say put a
NAND here or a NAND there.
Stochastically, I'm going to
sort of put in a whole chunk
that I've already used before.
OK?
I'm going to sort of call
that a new primitive.
Cut out this part of the space.
Under the hood, it's actually
an AND or something like that.
And discover-- so
discover is not an AND.
And discover is this
really useful thing
that they called E2, which
doesn't appear in logic books.
But it turns out to be really
useful for certain diagrams,
which is take an input,
split it into two,
do something on this part,
do something on that part,
and recombine it.
It turns out to be a
hugely useful concept
for circuit diagrams.
And this thing discovers it.
And once it discovers
it, it sort of reuses it.
And what that does is it turns
an infinite and unmanageable
space into infinite, but
a bit more manageable.
OK?
So your space is infinite.
You're not going to search
the full length of it.
Imagine that this is a space
of all possible programs.
As you go down, the
programs get way too long.
You're never going
to reach them.
But some of them
are really good.
Some of them are really
good explanations.
And the only way
to get to them is
if you had some sort
of way of chunking
the problem, of saying, yes,
it looks like a long program.
But actually half of it
I've already used before
to solve a different thing.
And half of it is less
long than two times.
So you might discover,
you know, you might
have an effective search area.
You find out all the
problems you can solve there.
Yeah, this is an interesting
thing, choice color.
So imagine that of this
blue thing over here
is describing, within the
space of all possible programs,
the sort of programs
that you want to find.
So there's the
effective search area.
They only cover part
of this blue thing.
You can think of it
like the probability
is really high over there.
You really want to
find all of them.
But by searching
that small space
and, within that small space,
finding the right primitives
and encapsulating them,
you can now actually
search more efficiently
the rest of the space.
And the rest of the space sort
of compresses and compresses
until it's all within your
effective search area.
Do people sort of
understand that?
It's sort of there
were long programs
before that you never
would have gotten to.
But by searching
these small spaces
that you could search
through before,
discovering the
useful parts there,
these new things that
seem really long before
are actually short.
Because they can be described
by just a few chunks.
OK?
This is a really
interesting work.
And I encourage you
all to read it, those
of you who find it interesting.
The last thing I'm going to
do-- and then that'll leaves 10
minutes to discussion,
which is great--
is this problem
that I guess maybe
it's really the heart of
what Laura is getting at.
I think she was not satisfied
by any of these things.
And she was sort of pointing
out, well, fine, you
can do stochastic
search all you want.
But the really hard problem is
constructing the space itself
on the fly.
You're not going to
use one infinite space
for all possible problems.
You're going to use the right
spaces for the right problem.
And how do you do that?
In this case, we're going
to do, give me a good name
for a romantic drama.
All right.
And your search space is going
to be imagined that-- can
people see sort of the border?
Like, there's this whole
space of uselessness.
And what you really
want to do is
focus in on that tiny
part of useful things.
If only there was a
way of just on the fly,
you know, zooming
in on that thing
and then bouncing
around in that.
And the point is to say, well,
when we construct the space,
we can just use
previous examples.
I don't think it's
the case that we just
knew something
necessarily completely
new in these sort of
everyday thinking.
Well, maybe.
We can argue about
that in the discussion.
What you actually start
out with is actually
taking a few examples that
you find relevant in some way
and using those examples
to then construct
your space on the fly, right?
You might think
about things like,
what other romantic dramas
do I remember in the past?
What do they share in common?
What movie names do I
know of in the past--
quickly finding the sort
of relevant thing for all
these things, and then
having the space for those,
and then searching
around stochastically.
Because you're not going to do
better than stochastic search.
There will come a point where
you're just bouncing around
at random.
So I used this actually, forgive
me, a paper title for SRCD
and came up with
some amusing things.
You guys can play with
that online if you want.
But let's do, give me a good
name for a new romantic drama.
So as I said, what you would do
is you would just think about
all the romantic dramas that
you know, like The Climbers,
Christine of The Big Tops,
Cupid's-- these are all actual
romantic dramas pulled
off of Wikipedia--
then use those to
construct your space.
Don't care about all the things
that could happen in the world.
OK?
And what do we mean
construct your space?
Well, there's a bunch of
ways to look the space.
What ideally we would
want and what I didn't do,
but what we're thinking
of, is to construct
a very, very simple
grammar which
instead of all
possible sentences
is a grammar for movie titles.
And this grammar usually tends
to generate things like the,
right?
The something something.
And [AUDIO OUT] long.
And then it just stops.
OK?
And it turns out that something
like the adjective noun
is a really good way of
generating names for pubs--
The White Queen, The Blond
Tiger, The Bleeding Bottle,
I don't know, something.
Right?
That's really useful if
only it could do that.
If it could construct
these tiny grammars,
it'll still give you an
infinite number of things.
But, you know,
[AUDIO OUT] movie names.
Or things like
verbing proper name
turns out to be a really good
thing for like, you know,
Amy Stopping,
Interrupting Timmy.
It's so bad.
And you could find that from
looking at these things.
And just to show
you how much I think
that this is, you know, actually
not that bad of a problem,
I did not this grammar thing.
I did something
even simpler, which
is to take all the other names
that I could find on Wikipedia
for different movie genres
throughout the ages,
and then I looked at things
like romantic dramas.
And what I did was construct
a very simple n-gram which
just takes those words
and just sort of does
random walk on those words.
OK?
And you could imagine
complicating this immediately
by taking something
like embedding
those words in the
high-dimensional space
and actually picking words
that aren't close to that.
So you could get new words that
were never in there before.
I'm not even doing that.
I'm doing something
ridiculously simple
that I don't think
people are doing.
But let me show you
how reasonable it is.
OK?
And what I'm going
to compare it to
is some stuff that we ask
people on Mechanical Turk
to give us names for
a new romantic drama.
Ah, the only thing I
forgot was the right
labeling for these things.
So Laura, what do you think?
Is this from Turk, or
is this my algorithm?
LAURA SCHULZ: I am
50/50 [AUDIO OUT]..
TOMER ULLMAN: So how about we'll
have by, not show of hands,
but people just shout it out.
Like, if it's, I
don't know, Turk or--
I'm looking for a short word
which is like a Turk or Tomer.
Let's do it that way, so Tomer
just standing in for Tomer'
simple silly algorithm.
So who thinks that
this was created
by someone an actual
human on Mechanical Turk?
And who thinks it was created
by Tomer mechanically running
through an algorithm?
OK.
So in 3, 2, 1 you're either
going to shout Turk or Tomer.
3, 2, 1.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TOMER ULLMAN: OK.
That was actually someone
at Mechanical Turk.
Let's do this again.
Girls In Ships for a
romantic drama, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Tomer.
TOMER ULLMAN: This
was an algorithm.
Value Of Love, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: That
was Turk, good.
Endless Love, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: Good.
OK.
How about Legend of Paris?
3, 2, 1--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TOMER ULLMAN: Nobody knows.
This is actually me.
OK.
Who's enjoying this and
wants to do a few more?
Land of Roses, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Tomer.
TOMER ULLMAN: Tomer.
And finally, Those We
Meet Again, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: No, it wasn't me.
Oh, sorry, one more.
Love Lightly, 3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: Yeah, Turk.
It seems like
Turkers were actually
doing better than the algorithm,
which is romantic is love.
And I'm just going
to put something
with love in the title.
So who wants to do this
action movies, and then
we'll start stop?
OK.
Let's do this for action.
How about The Chase?
3, 2, 1--
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: Yes, how
about Who, The Annihilation?
[LAUGHTER]
TOMER ULLMAN: OK, that's me.
The Oversight?
Turk.
The Edge.
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: Turk.
Jack Death?
Tomer.
Among Heroes.
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: No, it was me.
Swordmen in China Three?
AUDIENCE: Tomer
TOMER ULLMAN: Tomer.
And The Hit?
AUDIENCE: Turk.
TOMER ULLMAN: People on Turk.
You can probably [AUDIO OUT]
than four in each one.
And, again, people are like, The
Oversight, The Hit, The Chase,
The Edge.
That's the only thing they did.
They actually came up with
some clever stuff as well.
But, you know, it's interesting.
And, of course, I'm cheating.
Because the algorithm did a
bunch of really dumb stuff
that I didn't put in here,
like Hunchback of Monte Cristo,
Get it Did, Bell
of a Lesser God,
Eagles Shooting
Heroes, Tomb Raider,
The Raging God Of Violence, and
Legend of Legend, my favorite.
But my point is to say,
you know, in the same sense
that Joshua's saying,
you know, imagine
that you could use
something like a ConvNet
to quickly cede your proposals--
imagine if you could think
of like a random dumb algorithm
that could then [AUDIO OUT]
and say Legend of something.
And then you start to say, no.
That's not really a great idea.
What you're trying
to get at here
is not 100% accuracy
with these silly things,
but something like 1 in 5.
1 in 5 is better than 1
in 0, or 1 in a million
or something like that, which
is what Laura was pointing out.
OK.
So as I said, we still
have a long, long way
to go to model children
to meet Laura's critique.
It's hard to say what's hard.
I think that's what I was
trying to hint at with Steve
Piantadosi's point.
We don't really
know what's easy.
know what's hard.
But people in development
and in computational land
should continue to care
about stochastic algorithms.
And people in
computational land should
continue to care about
children to everyone's benefit.
And that's it-- so, Laura.
LAURA SCHULZ: This
will be very short.
[APPLAUSE]
So I didn't know.
Or rather, I did know.
But I didn't know
it was going to be
part of this debate
about Max Siegel's thing.
So I'll say something
briefly about that.
But you've had three really good
approaches to each of these.
So I'll speak
briefly about them.
I think what Owen is
doing is totally great,
but still driven in
some sense by the data,
not by the question, right?
And I think the point that I'm
going to make just continually
here is that the way we
think is driven by the goals
that we have, right?
And each of these
solutions in some ways
is failing to use what is
most salient to it as humans,
which is we have problems.
We have questions, right?
And what I would like to
do is see us move to a case
where it's not just
the data that's causing
us to generate new ideas.
And we're not just
trying to deal with that.
It is actually the information
in the problem itself.
Similarly, I think what Eyal's
doing is totally beautiful.
And the representational
compression
is really, really interesting.
But a lot of learning
problems can't be solved.
Most of the ones
I was gesturing at
are not really
problems of changing
the representational format.
It matters hugely that
we have an Arabic numeral
system instead of a
Roman numeral system.
That changes the kinds of
problems that we can solve.
And so that represents
a huge advancement.
And for many kinds
of problems, it
will make search
much more efficient.
But a lot of problems just
don't have that property.
So it's, in some
sense, an answer
to a different kind of problem.
Steve's proposal-- what
can you say, right?
It could be true.
There are a billion,
billion neurons.
You get more
synaptic connections
than there are stars
in the known universe.
Of course, it could be true.
That's what an expedition
means-- a long line
of everybody, says Pooh.
But it's not as good
a story if it's true.
So it could be true.
You could do a billion
things really really fast
and just think about the
ones that you arrive at.
But I think the jury's
out on that one.
Max and Tomer and this--
and while ago I think
Sam Gershman also, right?
So Sam Gershman
came up to us and we
spent a while talking about
how you would invent what
we were affectionately calling a
bullshit generator, our ability
to [AUDIO OUT].
Somebody asked me about
anything, you know--
tell me about Ionic
and Doric columns,
you remember something
from sixth grade.
And you start talking, right?
So the question is,
what can you do?
And I think this is a
really nice attempt.
And I think the idea of
seeding it from past examples
to help construct a search space
is a really beautiful idea.
Again, the question is,
how do you make that.
My feeling is still
we can do something
that works for those
kinds of problems
where we have past examples.
We can do it for
any kind of problem.
And so what I
really want to push
for is use the problem, right?
Use the information
and the problem.
Because for those problems,
like romantic movies,
we have some existing examples.
We can the search space.
We can do that.
And for my theater company
example, it's perfect.
But for the peppermint
example, not so much, right?
You're not going to see the
search space from examples
of candies, or what you
know about the construction
of candies.
If you did, it wouldn't generate
the pendulum answer, which we
think is a good wrong answer.
So it's not just that.
It is I have a problem
of a particular kind.
It is going to be satisfied by
some kind of an answer and not
others.
How can I use that to
help my [INAUDIBLE]??
So that's I think the end
of what I have to say.
And we'll return to questions.